you have the talent
whether you have the killer instinct is
the big question
i first just wanted to kick off by
asking you so many people are going to
go see this movie on the big screen
and a lot of them probably haven't been
to the theater in a long time and
they're going to enjoy that yay exactly
thank you
i want to know what it's meant to you to
go to the theater over the years sort of
the emotions that it's evoked how it's
impacted your lives
oh my god i i the theater
going to the movie theater is the most
trans
i mean that was the i think that's the
reason i wanted to be an actor i grew up
in arizona
where it's 120 to 125 degrees fahrenheit
you can't do anything outside in the
summer it's
miserable and going to a movie theater
which is very cold
and drinking icy and watching something
on screen and transfer i was also the
kind of kid that once i left the theater
i thought i was the character for a good
rest of the day at least so it was it's
just when it's that big and it overtakes
you and everyone's really focusing on
something especially now
when you're always looking at your phone
and there's other distractions it's just
it's the most i think it's the reason i
love being in movies is because they're
seen that way i think it's so special
and um movies on her phone exclusively
and i have a very small phone tiny um
[Laughter]
anyway uh i i grew up of course
it rather earlier in the 19th 20th
century i
nearly said 19th century which is sort
of that but that's because i'm
essentially a 19th century woman um
i grew up much more in the theater
because my parents were both actors
so for me um going into a dark theater
was my um i mean it was just
extraordinary and my parents because
they worked in the theater didn't really
taste to the cinema very much
but the first movie i saw was disney's
fantasia
and i mean it's still with me it still
haunts me
i still love it i still find it
completely
um transporting and i am
um theater and cinema together
were what made me want to to be an actor
actually i didn't want to be an actor
i wanted to be a hospital administrator
but let that pass
i've made a very good administrator
actually
you still need to play one in a movie
um so obviously i know glenn close is a
producer on the film
and emma stone you obviously need no
inspiration
at all from her this is such an inspired
performance by both of you
just incredible but did you draw
anything was there a nod was there
something an
ode uh to glenn to be honest
for for me i did not re-watch her films
once i was
making cruella because i did not want to
even try
to touch glenn close why would anyone
try
to emulate glenn close she is so
fantastic
and stands alone that i was like okay
this is a this is an origin story of the
character she's also transported into
the 70s which is a totally different
it's sort of taking the character and
just reimagining the story so
it felt it felt like it should be
a a reimagining for me as well and so
i um so no i i i wouldn't dare
try to uh do a pale comparison
to you know glenn gloves well not
looking back but looking forward i was
thinking of the godfather too when they
did a mashup of like brando and pacino
could you ever see like
because there's going to be a sequel to
this film i demand it um
like a mashup like a back and forth like
a prequel sequel kind of thing
i have no idea you're going to have to
talk to me
to do that right i'm writing the letter
now actually has anyone got any paper
dear mr disney oh is he still around i
don't even know
please can we do exactly what was just
suggested
in this interview i'm sending it now
because i think that's a brilliant
idea you're a writer emma you could
write this
um actually oh my god that's a really
good okay
okay
you know what before we get on to the
sequel should we just see
how the movie goes first it's a really
good idea
we should just see if people even want
this or if we're shoving it down their
throats
you know there is no way that's good but
we're already excited about the sequel
no we need to shut up
if emma thompson wrote it emma stone
you'd be on board oh my god i mean come
on
okay um going to on another tangent
could there be an avengers style
film where all of the villainesses show
up
in one movie oh my goodness you have
so many good ideas
are you a producer pretending to be a
journalist that's what i want to know
i'm hiding my producer hat under my
puffy sleeves
a lot of incredible ideas here uh but
could we see that
would that be cool and the baroness my
goodness she could show up too
i mean come on i know you need to go
pitch this
yeah you gotta go pitch this that would
be very cool um
i wanted to ask you emma thompson um the
baroness
because obviously this is cruella's
origin story
did you create an origin story for the
baroness because she must have had a
rich life before we see her
on screen did you create that for
yourself as an actress yes i do
i sort of did i mean i think that the
baroness
was clearly rather poorly parented um
which was not unusual in the
aristocratic circles of that day
but anyway it's fine she she's made it
work for her
uh and so her entire life
is centered around her her creative
genius which is
um certainly present and real i mean she
really is
an extraordinary designer but she's
unable
she's rather weak in in the sense that
she's unable to
tolerate any kind of competition um but
again you know that's not unusual at the
top
some people um don't can't cope with so
they have to stay up there and stay up
there and
and to do that they just tread on
everyone coming up beneath them
so she's um she's extreme cruella loves
to make an entrance
what is either the biggest entrance
you've ever ever made
or have you ever crashed a party i uh i
did this movie called the house bunny
when i was 18 and the after party was at
the playboy mansion because the
the film took place and there was
moments of the playboy mansion and as i
walked in
as is my uh way in life this tends to be
i was on a real
high i was really feeling great it was
one of the first movies i had ever done
and i walked in the big staircase and i
fell
flat on my ass flat i mean i walked and
it went
and it hurt so badly and so that was a
major entrance on your butt at the
playboy mansion she thought she owned
everyone
that's foolish unhinged well you're
fired
why are you speaking i think you mixed
me you pushed so many boundaries with
this film
um but it still feels very much like a
disney film it's a darker film than i
think we've seen before you're the
perfect guy to direct it so
how first question is how did you
balance that and still make it feel
disney so
every generation can go see this movie
it's a very that's that thank you for
noticing it's a really tricky thing i
wanted to say
you know i spoke with uh sean bailey
after
i tanya and i've done a couple of disney
films before so
we you know i'm very familiar with the
disney brand and and
and that tone but getting to do a
villain
it sort of takes it takes the handcuffs
off a little bit
and we could really go for it so it was
kind of this bizarre thing and nothing
like
i love the disney films but every time a
production head would come in
i'd be like we're not making a disney
movie they don't think of it like a
disney film
we're making this like coming-of-age
story of this you know a very grounded
thing so
you know particularly like wardrobe and
production design it was all very
grounded in that 70s punk world
and i brought my cinematographer
nicholas carrick katanas from
itanya and we're kind of just making
another
indie movie for a lot of money it's
funny because i think one of the actors
said that
on set i think it was emma thompson said
that it felt like an indie movie even
though the scope of it was so big
um i wanted to ask you as a director
because this is a movie
about a rebel what is the most
rebellious thing you feel like you've
done as a director
um i don't know if i could say
i don't know um i look i'm very
passionate about getting what i believe
in
um and it even on even on this film
there were a couple of times where
disney's like i don't know if we we
don't
really want to shoot that i was like
well i'm going to shoot it and i'll
shoot the other version
and you guys can decide in post but i
just wanted to get it on camera
wow how much did it make into the movie
and how much did it get
is there a director's cut like no like
actually in the film
so it was great wow wow was that the
thing that you first came to mind that
you're going to say i feel like it
wasn't
but sort of i tend to like in terms of
being
yeah there's been other times
there was there was a yeah there's been
time there was a moment on another set
where it's like i offered to pay
for the day because we weren't going to
stop wow
well i it kind of leads me into my next
question i mean i think everybody has
seen
the stills from pam and tommy that have
come out that have leaked you know not
leaked but you've released them online
and there's so much buzz about that um i
from i
tonya to this film to you're doing a
mike tyson series
why are you the director that tells
stories from the
point of view of like the baddie or the
rebel or the infamous rather than the
famous
i it's it's funny i'd say i don't know
why i'm attracted to that it's nothing
about my personal life i hope
um although i am i always have felt
somewhat like an outsider you know i
came from
australia when i was 19 to new york
living in a ymca and
never feeling like i was part of the
club and i think uh
and finding you know finding my way and
i i just really empathize with that and
i i just find it fascinating with all of
these stories
most people do bad things that don't
they're not bad people they don't think
they're bad people
they're good people doing bad things so
it's really figuring out like where
their head was
their motivation what the choices they
made and why they made them
and humanizing them and not necessarily
condoning what they're doing
but just understanding their situation
and
i get very intrigued with that yeah well
especially you know
in this movie they're so you know it's a
tough balance with emma's character emma
stone's character
to balance the bad with the with the
good the both sides the estella and the
cruella you did an amazing job um i
wanted to ask you
just the scope and size of this cause
watching it and i think it was the
costume designer that when she
first read the script said oh my gosh
this is an enormous
movie and i'm assuming this is the most
enormous movie you've worked on
what was the most challenging part of
all of that
you said again it's like i'm very
greedy as a director and there was a lot
of people saying we couldn't get
all of this in the amount of time that
we had
and i was just like yeah we can and so
we were shooting we shot 2 700 setups
in 65 days my a.d pointed out to me
which meant that we were shooting
lighting and shooting a shot every 25
minutes
which is why it felt like an independent
film
so that garbage truck shot um when she's
on the back of the truck i had eight
minutes to get like
we did two takes at three in the morning
in london
so which take made it one or two that's
crazy that's crazy
yeah so there was always this sort of
very phonetic pace and the crew was
amazing with it
and i think in some ways it gave us this
freedom because
once that once the keys like you know
nadia with hair and jenny with uh
you know wardrobe they would just be
running with it and it's like
you know emma would be like running off
and throwing in 20 minutes later in a
different hairstyle different outfit
how do you capture because one thing i
think you do really well as a director
is you capture the essence of a decade
and you
you know i tonya was set in the 70s this
is set in the 70s
and obviously you have great music i
mean the library this soundtrack for
this is off the charts but how do you
capture the essence of a decade the
spirit it's like you're on
you're so immersed in it the the
critical part for me is that you're not
drawing attention to it
um like i i for me i said i don't want
to i don't want the audience to suddenly
be like oh i love that outfit or i love
that
set it's like it's all got to fall off
into the background and just be part of
the story it's always going to be about
character first so
if there's something that's calling too
loudly for attention
it's not right in the film you know and
it's like i don't think
and there's also this other aspect that
you're never just shooting 1978
it's like 1978 and the 10 years before
you know like people don't buy all their
clothes that yeah they don't
drive they don't buy all their
appliances and
so there's this history that you get
yeah um can you
uh for pam and tommy so curious the tone
of it how is it going to feel
very iconic is it really
yeah yeah it's i'm really it's really
fun i just finished my fourth week on
that and uh
the actors are amazing the scripts are
great and uh
this is uh there's a surprising empathy
that you get to have for the characters
and this complicity again
that the audience has for being involved
in such a scandal you know
yeah oh yeah i think you know as soon as
the picture's dropped every
little that's lily james that's
incredible the prosthetics are amazing
it was
the makeup is doing an amazing job yeah
um
going back to cruella i noticed
something and my team was like you can
ask it if you want
i don't know if this was a choice but
we're talking about the scope of the
movie but i want to talk about something
very detailed
there is a scene where emma stone's
character corella has banana on her face
there's another scene where the baroness
played by emma thompson is eating a
banana in a car there's a piece of
banana and i re
i watched i had it at home and i ground
it i'm like there's banana and then she
chucks out the window was that a choice
that was not a choice it's a good catch
but uh we're trying to figure it's like
you know they've got so much makeup on
and what's not gonna mess with the
makeup
that she can eat in a way that's like
that works um and then the banana popped
in from somebody that day
okay so it wasn't like a tie-in like one
has banana
you know i love the way that scene
played out and you know it's on she
checks the wrong side of her face and
then she eats it and
it's great yeah did you at all talk to
ryan about emma since you worked with
ryan or emma about ryan did that
connection come into play at all uh it
actually didn't
um you know it's like uh you know we
never we never crossed i mean other than
just sort of casual things but
you know i know they're both very fond
of each other you have a bit of an
extreme side
yes darling what fun that is i want to
first ask you about
your name in this film anita darling now
anita
in the original the og animated film
cartoon was called anita but corello
would call her darling
so is this possible foreshadowing of
where this character could go was this
just a nod to the original
or or and did you sort of have a say in
any of it
i think that would probably be more of a
question for craig i did not have a say
in it but i
absolutely loved uh the the name i mean
i
i think that um what i love about even
the name anita darling is that the way
both these women
say it it's so trippingly off the tongue
it just makes
it adds to the sort of camp high drama
of it all
so i did not have a say in it but i
absolutely love it and i love when
everyone when anyone refers to me as
anita darling
i was hoping you would say darling
because ever since i've seen this film
i've been saying darling and i think
it's going to set up not only is the
fashion going to set off trends but
people are going to go back to saying
dog
oh i think we're going back to darling
yeah
that's kind of the wonderful thing about
this film is i think that it's almost
like
it's this wonderful movie that
transports you into another place and
it's almost like a travel film like to
see it you're like
oh that's london the way they speak the
way it looks the way it
feels it's it's like you get a taste of
the city and
and the tone and the way people speak
just from watching it
and that era in that era wow so this
movie is going to be such a massive
success
there are gonna there's going to be a
sequel there just is i'm putting it out
there in the universe or possibly a
spin-off what would you like to see with
your character as you
if you were to move forward and evolve
would you like to see a tie-in with the
anita
maybe she ends up because in the
original she had all the donations
right she was you know she found love or
what would be
your uh what would you like to see
happen what would i like to see that's a
great question i have not been asked
this so i'm going to think
fast um i think what i would like to see
is kind of more of what we've seen
in this film i think what i what really
drew me to it
is seeing a woman women multiple women
who are so ambitious and
really career driven and i think that
we're in a point
in the world where that is not odd
that's not an anomaly that's just a
truth that's been a truth for a lot of
us for a long
time but it hasn't been something that
people are
sort of always the most receptive to is
someone you know and
we all know there's a different stigma
with a man who's ambitious than with a
woman who's ambitious and i think
that i would just love to see in in
wherever this goes in the future to see
more of that just to have
you know more scenes opposite emma where
you see sort of
worlds collide because i think that's
what the beauty of this film is that
you're constantly seeing worlds collide
and that's
what creates the drama yeah i think um
you know the fact that your character
you play a gossip colonist
columnist but she takes her job very
seriously you you feel like she has
aspirations to go beyond that did you
research at
all because what it means to be a writer
photographer gossip columnist
back in the 70s is so different from
today
did you did you research sort of
the impact because your your writing
really changes the narrative
of how these characters go and how
they're perceived in the public
and then moving forward did you have any
role models like any journalists role
models
well i'll say this what's interesting is
uh
and obviously you know this because you
know you're part of this world
is that media has changed so much and
also the way we receive information has
changed so
what i found when i was doing my
research was which what was really
amazing was
you know in the 70s if you had a story
on the front cover that would be
all anyone talked about for weeks it
could be months even whereas now our
news cycle is so fast that you could be
on the front page of something which you
know most people aren't
it's not physical anymore anyway and
then it could then your
you know the next day no one even knows
what's going on and so i think that
for me understanding the impact of that
have really helped to build the
character to understand that
what she says and what she prints has a
huge
impact on not only the lives of both um
the baroness and cruella but also on
she's
she's kind of exporting culture at that
point to
london and to people and she's sort of
responsible for
for cruella becoming such a trendsetter
well said i'm like yeah it's true
and and it is power you had a very
powerful
role in the film um i want you you have
such an amazing resume
i wanted to ask you because you've
worked with your characters
uh your character worked with a lot of
baddies a lot of villainesses so i
wanted to ask you who is the cruelest
and baddest villain is it
the baroness from cruella villanelle
from killing eve
or bad janet from the good place ah
bad janet for sure oh bad janet you know
villanelle is
you know she's bad but she almost feels
misguided sometimes and
then you know the baroness i think that
to me the baroness is so
deliciously bad it's it's almost like
you can't help i don't think at any
moment you don't love her she just love
watching what she'll do and then i think
bad janet is just
it's just the dark side okay got it yes
no it's true i absolutely
by the way i i i see nothing wrong with
anything the baroness does well
a few things but you know you're right
delicious delicious i love that you use
that word it's one of my favorite
favorite words um have you done anything
very rebellious like have you ever
you know she crashes parties like
cruella loves to crash a party
or she goes incognito under the radio
radar have you what is the most
rebellious thing you've ever done
have you ever crashed a party i have
never crashed the party
so and if i if i ever do i think i'll
take a tip from
from um cruella and do it in style um
i can't think of the most the most
reminisce thing i've done currently is i
did this i dyed my hair and cut a lot
off so that's like
that's that's the that's not the most
that's the most rarest i can think of in
a moment
and the most sort of like oh okay you
did that without telling anyone so
i love it it was the first thing i was
going to say when we came on screen as i
was gonna say i love it i didn't know if
it was for a role or a personal thing
was it possibly inspiration
from you know i think that in in doing
cruella i think what was so amazing
about it is
seeing uh being part of a film that
pushes boundaries both
um as a narrative and it being kind of
you know
not what you'd expect from a disney film
but also fashion wise i think
what's been amazing is getting to do
press for something like this you can
kind of
let your freak flag fly and you know do
whatever you want because
that's that's this yeah be yourself be
who you are
and let that come through and that
people will take it how they'll take it
so
i think it's it's been really really fun
to be part of a project like this that
you can lean into personally also
i'm asking everybody today if a
personality was a pie chart i think we
all have a little cruella and all
have a little estella in us your
personal
what would be your pers your percentage
what percentage do you have cruella and
what percentage
stella i think i'm 60 40
60 cruella 40 because i think the
wonderful thing about cruella is that
she understands that it's almost like
good to be bad it's this thing of
if people want to think you're bad have
fun with it and i
love that i like i kind of love that
idea of not
caring not taking things ex really
personally not so
really caring what people think of you
and recognizing that people will think
whatever they'll think and your job is
just to present you
what other disney villain do you think
needs an origin story a live action
origin story
ursula from the little mermaid i gotta
know how she
how she came to be i have to
she's turning my dogs my first question
to you is
you know cruella is a little bit of a
rebel well a lot of a rebel
what is the most rebellious thing either
of you have ever done
in life in your careers have you crashed
a party
or have you you know it made a big
entrance gone under the radar
i i can't tell most of my stories
in any setting what about you yeah i
i i don't know man i don't really want
to you don't want to be
you don't want to be telling those
things to kind of i don't know
however many people would be working i
will say this
i i like messing with celebrities when i
meet them
uh like just saying or doing something
silly to put them off and
when i was at the sag awards the one
time i got to go
as a guest i saw bradley whitford
and rather than being like oh west wing
or
oh get out i saw him and i go hey man
billy madison
i love billy madison so for me it was
like a frat boy
compliment but he he looked kind of
pissed off at me and he went
hey man and walked right away like no
way
i just interviewed him for um for
handmaid's tale
but so i would think he would appreciate
that he's very kind of like quirky
he might have been being funny he's a
tremendous actor but i've made it
uh a habit now anytime i see him i'm
just gonna say billy madison
so yeah well there you go and then he'll
remember you you're the billy madison
guy
um joel any little stories you can share
crash the party going under the radar i
don't know but
i'll go back to you i'll think about it
now i'll think about as we as we're
going on and there might be something i
can
i can dredge out from my cloudy memory
this says a lot that you can't share a
lot but i mean i think it's a rite of
passage as a brit that you crash a lot
of parties right
the only way to apply really i mean
unless you crash the party it's kind of
the norm um
so obviously paul we know that your
co-star here was amazing but i want to
talk about your other co-star and that
was wink
wink the dog the chihuahua oh what kind
of a co-star
was wink i mean you know it's a fabulous
film
when he even goes incognito and has
wardrobe and goes under the radar and
crashes the party so
how was it sort of navigating all that
you also have a scene where you kind of
have an altercation with some dalmatians
how did that go it was tough you know
the dogs
uh have to have a tutor on set uh
because they're still
going through obedience school um so
that combined with
you know they were very needy it was
like hey can you throw me a bone here
and i'm like what do you need and the
dogs are like no really
throw me a bone and um and it was just
they were they're very needy and they
were all real
divas i thought more so than either of
the emma's wouldn't you say joel
they're kind of demanding the dogs i
would say that very very very demanding
and very
short very short with you you know not
very good people skills
yeah just hungry all the time demand to
take breaks
the whole thing yeah or you'd walk up to
them and you'd be like hey
little guy and they go no not right now
i'm in
in character
i hope you're only going to tell that
joke to me by the way that's perfect
the first time i've told it so
uh joel there is a scene between
your character and cruella that already
the people that i know that have watched
the film
are i'm going to use a very millennial
term but shipping the two of you
and seeing a romance between both of
your characters
um but you're also so was your character
in love with cruella is he
could there because i'm seeing a sequel
already is there potential for that
no yeah
friends man they're like we're like the
gang and
uh and we're sad that she's
well essentially losing her mind i guess
um
and yeah no it's not i think the film's
kind of fully up already
with enough stuff i don't think that's i
don't think that's the vibe
really so you didn't feel that when you
were filming like you didn't have that
because people are taking that from it i
mean could it be like a ross rachel
friends situation where it ends
up being something or i took it more as
this is like
more like you were like you said you
grew up together yeah i think it's
well personally i think it's more of
friends like good
family really actually more than friends
family because
they haven't got anybody else so they
have to kind of stick together
but but yeah that's what i think of it
paul's going to say something now
and yeah i'm not sure if it's if it's
still believed
i was just going to say that i i think a
lot of audience members are gonna leave
this film
asking the question will they or
won't they make coats out of the dogs
[Music]
what is there when you join a disney
movie is there a henchman school
the two of you are the perfect henchman
do you learn tricks of the trade did you
research it at all like could you pick a
lock asking for a friend
not asking for myself what's the problem
i'm
woefully incapable of anything that cool
i don't know
i would be horrible in a heist situation
i'd be on my phone
trying to postmates a meal while
everyone else was
throwing ninja stars and jumping through
windows what about you bud
when i was a child i kind of i started a
toy once like a toy soldier when i was
like really young
and then felt really really guilty about
it and i hid it somewhere
and i left it there because i couldn't
face kind of um
getting it so that was maybe my that was
my training maybe that's my shame thing
as well maybe that's my reckless
that's my that's like two an answer to
two questions that's my breakfast
that's my reckless moment as well
the moment was stealing a toy soldier
when you were fine
seconds true rebel um
i want to ask both of you and i'll start
with you paul
this is going to be the first film that
a lot of people see back in theaters
after not seeing a film for a long time
i know you're both cinephiles
so what is sort of going to the movies
meant to you how has it changed your
life
impacted you that feeling of being in a
theater
i i love movies joel and i think have
pretty good taste in film
we're really proud of this one and i
think if we're trying to get people back
to the theater this is kind of
this is kind of the perfect movie to do
it right it's you know big action
adventure
sort of comedy with a lot of heart and a
lot of visual
pomp and circumstance what this film
certainly has to offer
is there's not many films you could take
your
child to go and see and also
your parent and all of you will enjoy it
and um and yeah and like it and then and
that's kind of perfect for now because
yeah we need we need some films like
that now and it really is that kind of
film i mean
all the generations will enjoy it and
that's
that's cruella estella
if your personality your own personality
was a pie chart what personality what
percentage are you cruella
what percentage are you given estella of
your own personality
instead of 30 cruella i'm gonna say
i'm i'm probably 85
dalmatian based on how often i'm trying
to sleep or use the toilet
and the other 15 is probably cruella i
don't
i don't know that i have any of stella
i'm not a sweet
you know sewing kit type of person i'm
either causing havoc or trying to hide
from people
[Applause]
don't worry there's lots more bad things
coming perhaps
perhaps
perhaps